here it is the concluding review to the
concluding chapter of a very epic
trilogy the reviews themselves aren't as
epic as the epic trilogy but I'm just
I'm just saying there's epic in there
somewhere
the Lord of the Rings The Return of the
King funny it's not every day that
there's actually a spoiler in the title
of a movie
and speaking of spoilers like my other
Lord of the Rings reviews I'm gonna
spoiler the hell out of this video ye be
warned though the beginning of Lord of
the Rings Return of the King we actually
get a surprising backstory about Smeagol
aka Gollum I already did the voice dude
it shows Smeagol and Diggle their
fishing and then Smeagol wants the ring
alright I did it cuz you're all nice
about it and then it shows him like
deteriorating and becoming Gollum that
we all know it's a really dark segment a
lot of really creepy sound effects and
it shows him just eatin fish raw and
it's just all gross everyone always over
uses that term dark with movies like oh
it's so dark I've probably used it
myself I'm just saying the ghullam
segment in Return of the King pretty
dark I'll get the Frodo salmon Gollum in
a bit first of all we're going to talk
about Gandalf Aragorn Gimli and Legolas
and when they come on to Isengard now
this is a really important scene because
the extended additions to the Lord of
the Rings movies I like seeing the extra
content but when I'm watching it I I'm
like okay I get why it was cut from the
theatrical release if you're a fan of
the Lord it's cool seeing some of the
stuff it's cool seeing it go into more
detail but if you're a first time
watcher I get why the call was made was
like let's take this off of a theatrical
release
well Return of the King has two scenes
to power scenes where I'm like that
should never have been cut from the
movie and one of them is when Gandalf
and all them come on to Isengard if you
have to release they're all like all
right we got a wizard to deal with let's
deal with Saruman ya know it's like no
he hasn't any power anymore let's just
leave there's no resolution with this
character at all in the extended edition
Gandalf and Saruman like in the book
they have words they talk it's a cool
scene I love when awesome good and
awesome bad talk with each other I don't
know why I just love it so basically
they have words and Gandalf establishes
his power over Saruman busts his staff
in Wormtongue stabs him Legolas shoots
Wormtongue and then Saruman just falls
off of Orthanc and impales himself
you're like yep well he's dead and the
original theatrical release you would
have no idea about that you'd be like
what happens to Saruman does he just go
away does he become an old guy does he
play bingo for the rest of his life does
he go on America's Got Talent as to what
you gonna do guys Saruman is that what
he is to become you never know he's
probably that guy though and due to the
curiosity of Pippin they find out Sauron
is making a move against Minas Tirith
Minas Tirith is pretty much the capital
of the human world and Gondor is where
the king would sit had he come back he
has not come back so now it's in the
hands of lesser men otherwise known as
denethor is boromir's father and pretty
much sees his second born fairy mirrors
you know a piece of [ __ ] he's played by
John Noble you might know him as Walter
Bishop from fringe and he's a douche I
call him dick authority cuz that's what
he is
douche bag if ever there was one war is
going to come just wipe out everyone at
Minas Tirith
Gandalf knows this and he's like we need
to prepare for battle tikka Thor's just
like I don't bow to this Ranger from the
NAS one of my favorite parts is Oz gilja
it gets overrun by orcs Oz Gilly asks
this little town is divided by a river
part of the kingdom of Gondor so dick a
Thor's like hey Faramir you're gonna go
there and you're gonna take it back
you're probably gonna die yeah but you
know if you're gonna take it back you're
gonna do it because role of gun knows
mine and then Pippin singing this song
and all the troops are running into
battle and all the orcs are drawn their
boats it's all in slow motion it's a
really sad song you're like Missy
moments like that or why I love Lord of
the Rings by the end you're like that
was such an emotional variety it was
crazy
then you have Phaeton and Rohan they're
like all right let's amass an army to
help me to stare at that they're not
getting a big army than Aaron's like oh
it's okay I'll go on this path and get
the most broken army ever he has to get
this ghost army who are a bunch of oath
breakers and I get it but when it's
happening I'm like I just rather see the
meanest terrorist stuff right now we're
the further one Sam stuff then we jump
over to Frodo Sam and Gollum Gollum was
like you know what screw these hobbits
I'm gonna kill them and take the ring
for myself because he's a douche so he's
taking them up the staircase by Mina's
Morgul which is where the nazgûl hang
out and into this cave where there's
this big spider you saw in two towers
how do you know the weight of the ring
was really weighing on Frodo his soul
and physically she was getting heavier
as they get closer to Mordor but you
really notice in this movie the weaker
Frodo gets the stronger Sam needs to be
and that's what he does this is where
Sean Ashton really shines a Samwise
Gamgee he was two standout performance
in the entire movie because it was
sowing
expected you know the end of two towers
where they're both talking they're like
Oh will there be a book written about
this and Frodo's like oh you forgot one
of the chief characters Samwise the
brave frota wouldn't have gotten too far
without Sam and in movies and real-life
friends say that to friends because they
want to moralize him but they really
don't mean it are usually like yeah I'm
the main character and you're the friend
but in Lord of the Rings Frodo was 100%
correct without Samwise Gamgee Frodo
would fall fail and die trying
and as Samwise Gamgee is the voice of
reason infer those had golems pretty
much the devil Samwise Gamgee sees
Gollum talking to himself talking about
how he's going to kill the hobbits and
take the ring for himself and Sam just
starts smacking him around he's like he
said he's gonna murder I thought it was
like I'm not sending him away cuz he
sees some sort of kindred spirit and
Gollum that Sam just doesn't have and
it's frustrating and stupid to watch
Fredo sees Gollum as the one who
understands what it's like to be with
this ring for a while how much it weighs
on you the addiction you have to it
Samwise Gamgee will never feel that way
he'll never actually understand that but
he is the voice of complete objective
reason but hobbits as well as people
they go on their emotional state and so
they make it logical decisions that
wasn't seen in the movie I hated
watching this when Gollum manipulates
Frodo so much that Frodo tell Sam to go
take a hike and Sam's all crying and
when I saw that I was like I don't like
that it's important for the characters
to feel that lowest low in a movie like
this so I get it when you watch it you
just it sucks you feel like evil is just
one it's small little victories that's
right the good guys won at Helm's Deep
but Gollum one here you're like oh man
poor Sam he's just gonna hang out with
no limbus bread gonna be lonely crying
then you're like how's the fight at
Minas Tirith going maybe the humans are
having a little bit of better luck
they're not it's abysmal it's crazy over
there you got nazgul flying and
screeching picking up guys on horses and
throwing them over walls yeah like the
walls of Minas Tirith the city you got
that one orc general dude it sounds like
doctor cloth yeah this is it you're like
holy to face the orc however they got
the white wizard and as Pippin says that
has to account for something Gandalf is
a complete badass he's swinging that
staff around his sword he's just slicing
dudes down one of the best things is the
orcs are battering this door in this big
gate and Gandalf's like you are men of
Gondor whatever comes through that door
you're gonna stay your ground
you're gonna fight and that door gets
bashed in and three completely armored
trolls come running through and even God
else like oh you just tell him his face
he's like didn't expect that that's a
lot of bad dead and stepping up because
into tower stand it was kind of like oh
I don't want to do this and he whined a
lot and I was like that and why are you
bitching but in this one man he's giving
speeches Return of the King is all about
the speeches he's clacking swords is
like we're gonna die today it's gonna be
awesome
they charge into battle I'm pretty sure
I saw an orc who looks like beast man
from he-man I did he's there the battle
is just so heavy the first disc of the
special editions build up and you get it
alright cool you got a couple things
really cool in the beginning then you're
building up to the big fight but the
second disc of the extended editions
just it's epic there's no other way to
say you look up epic in the dictionary
it's like this two of Lord of the Rings
Return of the King extended edition dude
and I forgot to mention this character
my two towers review so I'm gonna
mention right here Aon I really like a
one usually these tough chicks who were
like no I want to fly it they come
across as really [ __ ] chicks who have
something to prove and you're like I
you're just annoying me Michelle
Rodriguez why are you doing this but
Aaron's like none not only will I fight
in this battle but I'm gonna take on the
witch-king of Angmar alright fine
you've earned your stripes today man but
for every white wizard and big army
coming down a hill fighting a huge
battle and what you're like alright
sweet is it enough no it's not Aragorn
comes on these ships and he's just like
alright guys I got my big ghost army up
up down down left right left right B a
start boom I just broke the game I
cheated I won these doses fly through
and wipe everything out and you're like
alright well I guess that's over now
I take comfort in the fact that it's not
like the entire movie was broke and it's
not like it was like oh it all built up
to this war been a bunch of
indestructible ghosts came through and
wiped out about a hundred thousand bad
guys and that was it that was the end
this was a victory but it's not the
victory the point is still Frodo getting
the ring into the volcano and destroying
evil
meanwhile in Shelob slayer Dolan has led
Frodo into a trap where a big spider is
going to eat him yeah Gollum is a
treacherous little bastard however
Samwise Gamgee learns about it and dude
I'm telling you
Samwise Gamgee having the light of
Ellendale and sting in his hand he's
like put him down you won't touch him
again your life dude Samwise dude and he
fights the spider and you're like dude
more impressive than
army of ghosts taking out a hundred
thousand orcs you betcha this is a
personal battle and it's headed up by
Samwise Gamgee Sam Weiss fights this big
gross disgusting spider and he wins
throat Oh gets captured by orcs and he
goes up this tower and starts wiping out
orc sure like Sam
holy [ __ ] where was this this whole time
meanwhile over at Minas Tirith they all
have a few decisions to make it comes to
this moment where they're all sitting in
Minas Tirith they've won their victory
they're like all right 10,000 orcs now
block Frodo's path to Mount Doom they're
like what to do and Aragorn it's like we
go up on the Black Gate and we call
Sauron and his army out we keep the eye
fixed on us we draw the entire army to
the gate to fight ass that will clear
the road for Fred up and aimers like we
cannot achieve victory through strength
of arms
Aragorn is like it's not for ourselves
but we can't get Fred of this chance I
love that [ __ ] dude that that's amazing
they all agree to go up on this gate and
be like we're probably gonna get wiped
out but we're going to do it to give
Frodo a chance to succeed if we don't do
this he won't succeed and then blackness
and darkness just gonna cover the land
anyway so there's no point we will die
so Frodo can succeed that's that's
awesome mom was like that or why I look
at Return of the King specifically and
be like yeah you did that and you're
awesome for it and so that's exactly
what they do and this is moment - that
was taken out of the theatrical release
where I was like why did you take that
out this guy comes out he's the mouth of
Sauron he's pretty much sarang's voice
and will he says duty as a really big
gross mouth can't see his eyes he has a
really big helmet booth Glee beard he
comes out and he has Frodo's me throw
vest he throws it to Gandalf and he was
like oh he died horribly by the way your
little friend
and then the hobbits to start they start
tearing up - like Frodo and you can tell
this guy's like all right what do you
mean by that
Gandalf like silence because really
Sauron doesn't know that Frodo is there
with the ring he probably suspects it
but yeah they were about to blow the
whole thing the whole point of them
drawing Sauron out to the Black Gate yep
there's about to be negated and Aragorn
slices his head off and he's like I
don't buy it but deep down you can tell
he does he was just really disheartening
and demoralizing it made him angry so he
selects the dude's head off who wouldn't
know if this whole scene was cut out of
theatrical cut why don't know after
those negotiations come to a complete
and abrupt end then the gates open up
and then we have ourselves a fight of
course people are like I don't want to
be here and Aragorn gives this whole
speech it's
pretty much one of the William Wallace
that can take our lives but they'll
never take our freedom kind of speeches
get you jacked up you're like yeah you
know what I'd probably stick around
after his speech like that right then it
goes back to Frodo and Sam Frodo just
Falls they're going up Mount Doom they
have made it there they just need to get
into the thing Frodo is just on the
ground and he's just like you could tell
it it's he doesn't have anymore in him
and he looks terrible to me you look at
the guy you're like you are in bad shape
you know those pets on those save a pet
commercials you know for a cup of coffee
a day and Sarah McLaughlin music's
playing Frodo looks like he should be on
one of those commercials as one of the
bets say The Hobbit I'm telling you he
was in bad shape you know when he was in
the spiderweb and he looked like Daffy
morta from willow yeah he looks worse
now than that and Sam can't carry the
ring because it's Frodo's burden he's
the ring baron Sam's like you know what
and let us be rid of it I may not be
able to carry it for you but I can carry
you and he picks Frodo up like a sack of
potatoes on his shoulders and he just
walks up the mountain with him on his
back that's friendship and that's what
Sam wise Kim G's awesome and back on the
battlefield they're all ready to throw
down the entire human army marrying
Pippen and Legolas and Gimli Gandalf
Aragorn everyone's there at the black
case you could see Barre a doer and the
big flaming Eye of Sauron right there
looking at him and you can hear the
whole those old whispers of Sauron
talking to Aragorn
Aragorn drops a sword he starts walking
forward at this point he's heard from
the mouth of Sauron that Frodo is dead
so their initial reasoning for being
there and drawn the gaze away from Frodo
it's gone now and I'm pretty sure
sarang's talking to him right now in his
head telling him yeah you know what join
my side the winning side the side that
will come out of this ahead we can rule
it all together and with the recent news
of Frodo's death and by implication the
enemy having the ring Aragorn really has
it's just the lowest low he has no
reason not to do it except for his own
morality and he turns around and he
looks at his crew behind him he looks
like Gandalf his eyes are glazed up it
looks like he's tearing up he's like and
he just charges into battle and the two
hobbits immediately chase right after
him and then everybody else just charges
into battle you see with the belief of
Frodo being dead it's not about buying
Frodo time anymore it's about wiping as
many of these bastards out as
you possibly can before you die that's
big-time man and it was badass to see
can't help but just beam with pride if
these characters that don't actually
exist you're like yeah all the good
things about human beings the good stuff
then Frodo gets into mountain doom he is
there he is on the precipice over the
lava he has the ring all he has to do is
drop in Sam's like Frodo what are you
waiting for just drop it in let it go
throw those holding it out and has that
really creepy noise it the evil ring
ambience oh you know that plays when the
rings doing its thing had Frodo recoils
he turns around he has the ring I wasn't
ready for this I really wasn't he was
just like the ring is mine he just rips
it off the chain and Sam's like no and
you're like no he puts it on he turns
invisible Sam's like no and you're like
no best part is sauron's
I cuz when you put on the ring you turn
invisible Sauron can see where you are
soaked in the nazgûl you see the I just
go and look at Mount Doom if you've ever
seen an eye wreath in flames [ __ ] itself
that was the moment it happened you can
see it's like oh wait the thing is seven
feet from me otherwise known as the one
place that can be destroyed that's cool
get the [ __ ] over there I don't even
think that was paraphrase I think the
eyeball said exactly that to the nazgûl
and the nazgûl do that turn that Star
Fox 64 turn where's just 180 in midair
but luckily and this is the only time
the words luckily have ever been used in
terms of Gollum showed up but luckily
Gollum showed up and he just jumps right
on invisible front or just glows and
Frodo turns visible because he bit his
finger off he has the ring and Gollum
looks so happy doesn't give a [ __ ] the
world is going to burn he has his
precious he's jumping up and down like
oh yeah Frodo ain't having it and they
scuffle and they fall over the edge and
you see Gollum falling into the lava
with his ring and he's just clutching it
such warm embrace as he falls and the
cameras following him down you seem just
splat into the lava and he's burning
he's dying is one thought is to save the
ring and finally the ring burns and it
gets destroyed evil is vanquished and
wiped out and Bera doer starts crumbling
the eyeballs just flipping out just
burning everywhere and they're all like
holy [ __ ] frou frou
he's alive and he did it and you're like
he did it and we're all like he did it
and evil is vanquished it's done o Frodo
no he's fine he grabbed onto the cliff
and Sam pulled him up and now he didn't
burn and die now at this point you still
have like a half an hour of film left
because the movie still needs to wrap up
and you've heard me say this phrase
before I'm gonna talk about movies that
have long endings I call it The Return
of the King ending because it does have
a long ending but if you just stop and
sit back and soak it in like I did last
time I watched it I actually loved it
dude I teared up at the end it was it
was out of control because it touches on
themes you know it's like the hobbits go
back and they're all living their lives
Frodo is like how can you go back to a
normal life some things are just too big
time doesn't actually heal them you're a
changed person after carrying the ring
of power for a year I do like the same
with Samwise Gamgee sees that chick he
had a crush on he was like you know what
I'm gonna go talk to her and end up
getting married because he's like I took
on a big spider and I carried the ring
bearer to Mount Doom and we saved the
world if he doesn't get every chick in
the shower every day middle-earth is
just not a just place and the end really
feels like the closing of a book because
the elves are leaving middle-earth are
going to their their holy land pretty
much if there's a heaven in middle-earth
it's this place that the elves go and
they give Bilbo that honor which is
funny cuz I want to see what Bilbo does
in The Hobbit to really illustrate why
the elves gave him that honor I know
it's in the books and whatnot but I want
to see it I'm a visual person and Frodo
goes cuz he's like I there's nothing for
me in this world anymore I have done it
all I've burned my candle at both ends I
have nothing left to give and it's just
sad as hell and they're all crying all
the hobbits are crying and you're either
crying or you want to cry but you start
feeling the knot in your throat and it's
just it's brutal it's good though you
need a wrap up like that at the end of a
trilogy like this if you didn't at least
kind of feel like you wanted to cry yeah
something misfired somewhere I should
just say the Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King is the Lord of the
Rings The Return of the King because
awesome tacular probably doesn't cover
the Lord of the Rings movies but as this
is my rating system and this is as high
as it goes the Lord of the Rings The
Return of the King is awesome tacular
which Lord of the Rings do I prefer
yellow ship and Return of the King two
towers it's all one movie and it is my
favorite movie of all time for those of
you who have asked what's my favorite
movie of all time so I'm gonna ask you
what is your favorite movie of all time
whatever it is there's no real wrong
answer to this comment below let me know
and as always if you like what you seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more